The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Good.
So let us start.
So last time, we talked about
finding the spacetime geometry
produced by D3 brane.
Such just based on symmetry,
you can write down the metric
as the following.
So it's some function, and
then a Minkowski metric--
a Minkowski metric for
the 3 plus 1 direction.
And then the path for the
transverse direction, which
you have rotation symmetry.
So you should think of h--
the D3 brane as a point in R6,
then there's a
spherical symmetry
in R6 around this point.
And then there are other
3 plus 1 direction, which
is this 3 plus 1 direction.
OK?
So when you solve the
Einstein equation--
when you find that this f,
h, can be solved explicitly
by the following form--
some other function
of H by the same function,
with H given by--
and R is the constant, which
is given by the following form.
So R essentially
have the form of
some constant,
Newton constant times
the tension of the D3 brane.
And then you have N of them.
And then this can also be--
if you've written everything
in terms of Gs and
alpha prime, it
can be written as 4 pi gs
and alpha prime squared.
OK?
So this R-- so this is
just like what you normally
see in the Schwarzchild metric.
It's now G times the mass.
Except, because of the
translation symmetry
in this 3 plus 1 direction,
so we have the tension
appear here.
So GN is proportional
to-- so Newton constant is
proportional to gs squared.
And T3 is proportional
to 1 over gs.
So this product is
proportional to gs.
OK?
And there's N of them.
So there's N here.
And on dimension of ground,
this is dimension 4.
So you have alpha
prime squared here.
OK?
So again, you can
write down everything
on dimensional ground.
And the only thing
is just this 4 pi.
You have to be careful.
OK?
So this is the full
D3 brane metric.
So now let's understand a little
bit of physics of this metric,
which gave us a
deeper understanding
of the physics of D3 branes.
So first, let's consider
various regime of r.
OK?
So let's consider, say-- first
consider r goes to infinity.
So in r goes to infinity,
Hr just become 1.
H just become 1.
OK?
And then you just recover
a 10-dimensional Minkowski
metric.
OK?
So this is very
easy to understand.
You are infinity away
from the D3 brane.
Of course, you
don't feel anything.
And so you just recovered
the 10-dimensional Minkowski
spacetime.
So here is 1.
Here is 1.
Just is a funny way to write
down 10-dimensional Minkowski
spacetime.
So this is just
a flat R6 metric.
OK?
And now-- let's now
consider r go to infinity
is just only r
much, much smaller
than R-- than this capital R.
Then this function-- so again,
let me call this f.
Let me call this
H. So for example--
did I call them H or g?
H. Yeah.
So for example, the f-- it's a
similar thing with g, with H.
So the f will be 1 plus--
so something of order R
to the power of 4 divided
by r to the power of 4.
Similar with the H.
So now you recognize
that this 1 over r4
is precisely long range Coulomb
potential in six dimension.
OK?
In R6.
Because only transverse
direction matters.
And in three spacial
dimensions, if you have a point,
then you have 1 over r.
And in six dimensions, then you
again-- you go down two powers,
and then you get 1 over r4.
So this behavior can
simply be understood--
say, essentially, as you have
some kind of Coulomb potential.
Both due to the--
say the conserved--
both due to the
charge of the brane
and also due to the gravity.
OK?
So you have some
long range potential.
So now the interesting thing--
things become more interesting
is when r become of order
R. When r become order R,
then this Hr start to be
significantly different from 1.
OK?
And then that
tells you-- so this
is the-- when r order 1,
the deformation-- yeah,
at this range, the deformation
of spacetime metric from D3
branes becomes significant.
OK?
So in other words, this
capital R, this constant,
essentially signals the
distance from the brane
where the gravitational
effect becomes strong.
OK?
The gravitational effect of
the D brane becomes strong.
And in particular, you
can check yourself.
You can calculate yourself the
curvature radius now become
of order R. Or the
curvature itself-- yeah,
let me just say the
curvature itself becomes R
to the minus 2.
OK?
So essentially, the
R gives you a measure
of when the gravity
becomes strong,
or the scale of the curvature.
So we solve this
metric in the context
of the super gravity-- in
the context of low energy
effect of super gravity.
So in order for the
approximation to work,
we said before, we wanted alpha
prime times the curvature to be
much, much smaller than 1.
So we said less time.
So that means we want this
to be much, much smaller
than 1 so that the super gravity
approximation can be valid.
So now, if you look at
expression of the R,
so this tells you that
the gsN must be much,
much greater than 1.
OK?
Yes.
N must be much,
much greater than 1.
And also, in order to have the
string loop crack into small,
we also need gs to be
much, much smaller than 1.
So we need gsN to be
much, much greater than 1,
but also gs to be much,
much smaller than 1.
So in order for the-- super
gravity approximation to work.
OK?
So now let's consider--
so when we set up
the problem, so this metric
is written that r equal to 0
is the location of the brane.
OK?
r equal to 0 is the
location of the brane.
When we solve this
problem, i equal to 0
is the presumed
location of the brane.
So now let's see what
happens when we-- yeah,
that's where you put the source.
OK?
That's where you put the source.
So now let's consider--
now let's ask
the question, what happens
to the metric if r goes to 0?
If we try to approach the brane.
OK?
We try to approach brane.
So this is very easy to do.
So when r become much smaller
than r to the capital R,
when r goes to 0, then
in this expression,
this term will dominate.
OK?
We can forget about the 1.
This term will dominate.
So in this case, the H will
be given by R to the 4-- R4.
OK?
Then we just plug this
into your original metric.
OK?
So you plug this back.
So when you plug this back-- so
H is equal to-- so H minus 1/2
then just become r squared
divided by R squared.
Then we still have dt
squared plus dx squared.
Then plus R squared
divided by r squared.
So it's positive 1/2.
Then dr squared plus r squared.
d omega 5 squared.
OK?
But now something
miraculous happened.
Something miraculous happened.
So let me slightly
write this metric
in the slightly
more explicit way.
When I write it-- so let me
just separate these two terms.
OK?
So there are two
important thing happened.
There are two important
thing happened.
Just to give you a-- yeah,
let me just do it here.
Yeah.
Let me do it here.
Maybe it's good enough.
Maybe that would be
good, just to be safe.
So previously, let's just
draw the product like this.
So let's call this R6.
OK?
Just for my purpose-- yeah,
let's consider this is the R6.
And yeah, forget
about what's outside.
Just imagine the-- yeah.
There's no outside.
Just the whole thing is R6.
OK?
And when we start
solving this problem,
the D3 brane-- D3 branes
are a point in this R6.
And then, there's some
flux coming out of it.
OK?
There's some F5 flux
coming out of it.
So this is the picture.
AUDIENCE: The flux
is normal to the F6?
PROFESSOR: Hm?
AUDIENCE: The flux
is normal to R6?
PROFESSOR: No.
The flux is normal to the
S5 surrounding the point.
And just like that.
I'm just saying, think about
the plane as a whole R6.
There's nothing
outside the plane.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I want to reserve the
things outside the plane
for other purpose.
I just now think about
R6 is the whole thing.
This is your whole space.
OK?
So if you look at
this situation,
there are two things.
First, there's a
source at i equal to 0.
You should see a data function
which is a source of the flux
and is a source of the mass.
OK?
There's some tension there.
And the other thing
is that if you
look at S5 around this
point-- and this 5,
when you go to the point,
then S5 will become 0 sides.
OK?
So around this point.
Yeah just in flat
space, around the--
if you write in the
polar coordinates--
so the sides of this S5
surrounding this point
become 0 sides when
you go to that point.
OK?
Yeah.
But now, if you look
at this metric--
now if you look at
this metric, now
actually when you
go to the-- when
you go to the
location of the brane,
actually, you never
reach i equal to 0.
Actually, this S5 will now
become a constant side.
OK?
Also, if you look at this-- so
there are two things happening.
So first this is 1.
This is 2.
So the first thing is
that S5 direction--
let me call S5-- now has
a constant radius given
by this R. So this
is the first thing.
And the second thing is
that, because of this,
the R squared-- over
R squared structure--
say if you write as the
proper distance-- write it
as a dl squared, so dl will
be the proper distance.
Then when you solve
this, then you
find l is essentially log
r, say, plus some constant.
Then as r goes to 0, the l
goes to-- when r goes to 0,
the l goes to minus infinity.
That means that i
equal to 0-- yeah,
let me just write it here.
This means i equal
to 0-- see it's
at infinite proper
distance away.
So for all practical purposes,
the brain has disappeared.
OK?
So the geometric
picture is that when
you include this--
when you include
the gravity of this source, so
now I have to draw something
called the embedding
diagram just
to use this extra direction
to show the curvature.
OK?
So when you go-- when
you approach this point,
what do you find?
You don't find the point.
Actually, you find there's
an infinite throat.
And so when you try to
go approach this point,
and this is the cross section
of this throat, which I can now
draw, is S5 with
the constant radius.
And then this throat has
an infinite long distance.
OK?
So l and here and have
an infinite distance.
OK?
So that's what's happening here.
And yeah, the sides of
this sphere, of course,
is R, of radius R.
So in this picture-- so when
you include, what we say,
the back reaction of the D3
branes, essentially the D3
branes themselves
have disappeared.
The only thing left are this
curved geometry and the fluxes.
Yeah, they're still--
the fluxes won't go away.
So you will still
see the S5 flux--
the F5 flux through this S5.
OK?
So there's still
flux through this S5.
OK?
Under this metric-- so this is
S5, which completely decoupled
from the rest of the parts.
So this have a constant radius.
So this S5 have decoupled
from the rest part.
So it's natural just
to look at this part.
And this is actually at
AdS5 So let me call it 1.
So 1 is just AdS5.
It's the metric of--
5-dimensional anti-de Sitter
spacetime times an S5.
OK?
And the idea is 5
have the metric.
So let me just copy here.
Essentially just
this part-- r squared
R minus dt squared plus
dx squared plus R squared
r squared dr squared.
OK?
So this is the S5.
So something magic has happened.
When you try to reach
the brane, then you
find the brain is
no longer there.
And actually develop
an infinite throat.
And this throat, the metric
is given by the S5 times S5.
OK?
And of course, at infinity,
you still see a flat space.
And infinity, you still
see a flat Minkowski space.
OK?
So now, we have to take a
little bit conceptual leap.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So we just basically
bound the most general solution
of gr with the given
symmetries given by the brane?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
With-- what do you
mean by most general?
We have specific D3 branes.
AUDIENCE: Well, so
we fixed the symmetry
given by the D3
brane, and then--
PROFESSOR: No, you also fixed
the D3 brane charge and D3
brane tension.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: That fix everything.
Yeah.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So what is the
nature of the source?
Originally, in D3 brane,
it's like electromagnetic--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --but now
it's like a mass.
PROFESSOR: No, now
the mass-- even
the mass is gone, you only
see a curved space time
and with some fluxes.
AUDIENCE: But I
mean, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
But the mass now
is completely gone.
It's, in some sense, sitting
at an infinite distance away.
You can never reach it.
And for all practical purpose,
if you leave this spacetime,
you will never see the source.
What you will see--
what you will observe
is just a curved spacetime
with some fluxes.
And this R also,
perfect solution
of the Einstein equation.
Yeah, because away
from the source,
it's also perfect solution
of Einstein equations.
Yeah, you have first?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so I was
just trying to understand.
So the point is that-- so is
this somehow protecting us
from these issues that--
even electromagnetism or even
quantum electromagnetic
field has issues
of like the divergence, of
kind of going towards a point
charge?
PROFESSOR: Right, right.
AUDIENCE: So is this
somehow getting around that
by making it go far away?
Or not really?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
No, this is not
getting around that.
This is-- the solution
presents itself.
We did not dictate the solution.
This is pure mathematics.
And we're just trying to
interpret these mathematics.
AUDIENCE: But it does achieve
that-- I mean, we didn't--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah, achieved that.
Right, right.
Yeah, just the solution
presented itself.
AUDIENCE: That's crazy.
OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So all the
electromagnetic charge,
wouldn't this tear
the space like this,
but at least [INAUDIBLE].
What about other [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, something
similar will happen,
but the story is even
more complicated.
And so the D3 brane,
the metric is simplest.
Yeah, for reasons that
I will mention later.
So the reason I choose
D3 brane is just
because of the-- the
metric is the simplest one.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: So the long-range
Coulmomb potential,
that's from the
charge of the brane?
PROFESSOR: Both.
AUDIENCE: OK.
You can't really
separate them I guess.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, in
principal, you can separate.
It'll depend on your probe.
Yeah.
But from the metric--
from the metric,
actually, from the
metric it's just
from the assumption that
come from the-- from metric,
of course, you
should just interpret
that as the gravitational part.
Yeah, this is just
gravitational part.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So there, you'll draw the flux
as flowing out of the cylinder
or along the cylinder?
I guess it's along the cylinder.
PROFESSOR: No, no.
Not along the cylinder.
Along the cylinder
is the r direction.
The flux is in the S5.
Just think of a hollow S2.
Think of a hollow square.
Think of a hollow S2.
Then S2 you can
have magnetic flux.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
And the flux is all over
the radial direction.
PROFESSOR: And then there's
no radial direction.
If you only have S2, then
there's no radial direction.
Just only have S2.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: And then you
can have a flux on that S2.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Something proportional
to F theta phi,
say in the natural magnetism.
Yeah, so this would be a
magnetic flux in the-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yes.
But you write it like in R6.
If you write it in R6, it is
along the radius direction.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Just forget about the--
in this picture it's back
in the radial direction.
But once we're in this
picture, and then this
becomes completely coupled.
AUDIENCE: Oh, oh.
I see.
PROFESSOR: And then you
just have separate S5.
AUDIENCE: I see, yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah.
OK.
So now, we have to do a
little bit conceptual leap.
It's not too big.
It's that now we have
two of the three braes.
OK?
So in the description one,
you just have a D brane.
You really just have some
Dirichlet boundary conditions
in flat Minkowski
10-dimensional spacetime,
and where open strings can end.
Where open strings leave, say.
So in this picture, you
just-- you specify some plane,
some surface in the
Minkowski 10-dimension.
And so this is R3.
Say 01, 3 if you include
the time direction.
So you just specify some
plane in the spacetime,
in the 10-dimensional
spacetime where, on this plane,
you can have open
string citations, OK?
And then the system, of course,
can also have closed strings.
Then this close
string can interact
with the brane, can interact
with the open strings,
et cetera.
And the only-- so everything
is in the flat space.
Everything is in the flat space.
And you have open string, you
have close string, open string.
Even on the brane,
the close string
can interact with the
brane, can-- a close string
can interact with open string.
In particular, for example,
you can send the close string
and absorb by the brane, and
then decay into open string.
It's possible.
So this just goes
one into say, yeah.
Or you can have two
open strings collide,
then become a closed string,
and then jump out of the brane.
Yeah, you can have all kinds
of this kind of interaction.
The key point is that in this
description, the only thing
you did is Dirichlet
boundary conditions
specified on some component
your worksheet fields,
for the string.
OK?
So this is-- but
now, from here, we
have also found the
different, second description.
Inside, we have
spacetime metric.
One which is some
curved spacetime,
them plus F5 flux on s5.
OK?
So here, there's no
D branes anymore.
We just have some curved
spacetime with some fluxes.
So here, the only thing
leaves is a closed string.
So only closed strings.
But those closed strings
see a curved geometry.
OK?
So now I can include
all dimensions.
To contrast these two, let
me draw this picture again.
Now let's draw a
10-dimensional picture.
So this is R, Minkowski 10.
So this is Minkowski 10.
So when you now go to
smaller radius r, and then
you develop an infinite throat--
so this becomes AdS 5 times s5.
OK?
5 down the throat.
And here, only closed
string can propagate.
There's no D brane, but the
closed string at infinity
in Ads5, so you can
have closed strings.
OK?
So is this clear?
AUDIENCE: What would
have closed strings?
Because in low energy
cases, no strings
would only have effective field.
PROFESSOR: But you have-- yeah.
But this is a geometry.
This provides the geometry.
In principle, the expectations
would be closed string.
Now you can do string
theory in this geometry.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
Oh, I see.
PROFESSOR: So now essentially--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
as a target.
New targets space--
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: Oh, and do
new string theory--
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So we started with a D brane.
And then we solved the geometry
due to the D branes-- geometry
due to that D branes.
And then now you can
quantize the string theory
in that new geometry.
Then that will
describe how things
interact with the D brane.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
But in this picture,
there's no D brane anymore.
There's only closed strings.
OK?
So we just have-- yeah.
Good?
Yes?
Hm?
AUDIENCE: What was F5?
PROFESSOR: F5, it's this F5 form
of the type IIB string, which
this D3 brane carry the charge.
So this generalized charge
I discussed last time.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: But in
last class, we know
the F5 is from the
effective theory.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And the effective theory is
from the open string spectrum.
PROFESSOR: No.
No, no.
F5 is close string spectrum.
AUDIENCE: Oh, it's
closed string spectrum.
So why can't we apply
string theory twice?
The first time we get a flux.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And then we get
to modify the targets with--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, right.
Yeah.
Yeah, you can.
String theory, you can work
with any field of spacetime.
You can think about
propagating a string
in the generic closed spacetime.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Because it seems like the second
application of string theory
is like a higher
order correction.
PROFESSOR: No.
No this picture-- this picture,
I'm just looking at-- forgot
about D branes.
I just look at
some charge object.
I look at some charge
object in string theory.
And that object have some
charge, have some mass.
Then I will call this metric.
I will call this metric.
And the string must be
able to live in that-- must
be able to live in that metric.
And if I want to work out
the property of the string,
then the metric-- I quantize
the string in this geometry.
And quantum string geometry.
So this point, if you were just
purely to view the D3 brane
as some charged object
in the string theory.
You just solve this geometry.
OK?
Any other questions?
So this is a very
important point.
It's a very important point.
So now, the key is that
consistency A must equal to B.
So these two descriptions
must be equivalent.
OK?
So this can be generalization
as the simple exercise
we described earlier.
That if you want to describe the
interaction between the two D
branes, you can do it
in two equivalent way.
One is to consider some loops
of open strings, which only need
to consider the flat space.
Just consider loops
of open strings.
Or you can see that the graviton
exchange between the two D
branes.
And the graviton exchange
between the two D brane
is to view that the other
D brane have already
curved your spacetime and
that the other D brane live
in that curved spacetime.
So this are a precise
generalization
of that equivalent.
OK?
Now we have two
descriptions of the D branes
which are completely
different-- this one involving
flash space and open
and closed strings,
and this one only
involving closed string
but in some curved spacetime.
OK?
And in principle,
both descriptions
can in principle be valid for
all value of alpha prime and g
string.
OK?
So the two parameters
in the string theory
is alpha prime and--
by all alpha prime,
just consider for all energies.
Yeah.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Why?
PROFESSOR: Hm?
AUDIENCE: It seems like
they're constrained, no?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah.
So first, in this
picture, there's
no restriction what is the
alpha prime or g string.
And you just impose the
Dirichlet boundary condition.
And when you have a
g string, you just
need to include the higher
loop diagrams, et cetera.
So when we work
out this geometry,
so this statement is
more try to apply to b.
In b, when we work out this
geometry, and also that AdS5,
we were working using
the approximation
that the alpha prime
should be small
and the g string
should be small.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: But once
we have worked out
that solution in these
regime, in principle,
if you're technically
powerful enough, you
should be able to extend this
to general values of g string
and alpha prime.
It may not be
precisely this metric,
but with some kind
of formation of
that from other
prime corrections
and g string corrections.
But you should be
able to do that.
Yeah.
Yeah, so that's why
I said in principle.
AUDIENCE: Got it.
PROFESSOR: OK?
So we must have these
two descriptions.
And these can be valid for all
range of the parameters you
can be interested in.
OK?
And so this is a very surprising
statement, this A equal to B.
But there's not
much to do about it,
because of this is
a complicated thing.
And this is also a
complicated thing.
This is even more complicated,
doing string theory
on some curved spacetime.
In particular--
say if you consider
g string is a very
small, et cetera, then
maybe you can do something.
But then it's not
that interesting,
because on both sides,
you do some perturbation
theory, et cetera.
Anyway.
But the remarkable thing--
which Maldacena realized in 1997
is that you can actually take
a limit of this statement.
And when you take a
limit of this statement,
then the statement
becomes very interesting.
Then you can actually do a lot.
OK?
And the limit is the
low energy limit.
So if you consider
the low energy limit,
then you derive what
is now called AdS/CFT.
We will now explain
how to do that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It seems like this
correspondence between A and B
only exists in the
low energy limit.
Because here, the closed
string is traveling
in the base spacetime.
That spacetime is only
the low energy corrections
from the D brane, not
the higher corrections.
Because we only solved the
low energy effective theory.
PROFESSOR: No, that's--
this is a good question,
but that's what I was
trying to say earlier.
So we find this metric by
working in this regime.
But now if I want to go
away from this regime--
if I want to go away
from this regime,
then if I want to go
away from this regime,
then I have to take into
account other prime corrections,
et cetera.
And this is a
complicated process.
But in principle, I can do that.
In principle, I can do that.
So that geometry may get
modified, the schedule.
But, in principle, I can do.
So now it turns
out, if you consider
lower energy limit
of this A equal to B,
then you can actually derive
a very powerful statement.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Is this actually
the lower energy limit?
PROFESSOR: No, this itself
is not low energy limit.
This is a classical
gravity limit.
AUDIENCE: What's the difference?
PROFESSOR: Hm?
PROFESSOR: I will explain that.
No, this is the
classical gravity limit.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: And at least
the low energy limit
does not involve this.
Yeah, I will explain what
this low energy limit.
Yeah.
Any other questions?
Good?
OK.
So now let's look
at low energy limit.
In particular, here, I
don't do any restriction
on the g string.
So g string can, in
principle, be strong here.
I don't impose any constraint
on the string happening now.
I only consider low energy.
OK?
So low energy
limit-- because when
I fix the energy,
E-- some process
I'm interested in, some typical
energy I'm interested in.
Then I want to take the
alpha prime go to 0 limit.
OK?
Or you fix-- equivalent,
you can fix alpha prime.
Then you take E equal to 0.
OK?
Because only the dimension
is product of the matters.
And I can describe either way.
OK?
So physicality, what is more
convenient-- mathematically,
normally what is more convenient
is that we think we fix E,
and then take alpha
prime goes to 0.
But you can think either way.
OK?
So the low energy limit
is essentially just
the limit of alpha prime
times e squared goes to 0.
That's the dimension statement.
OK?
So this is the low energy limit.
I only consider those
physical process with E
that would satisfy this region.
OK?
Good?
And I'm doing no
restriction on the gs.
So now, let's consider A. What
is the low energy limit for A?
For A, we know-- so A,
we have two factors.
We have open string factor,
which is live on the D brane.
Then we also have
close string factor.
OK?
Which live outside the brane.
For the open string
factor, we just recover.
So we discussed
before-- on the D brane,
when you go to low
energy, what do you get?
AUDIENCE: Super Yang-Mills?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
You just recover
your Mills series.
It just recover super
Yang-Mills series.
And in this case-- let me give
a special name for the D3 brane.
It turns out you get to the
n equals 4 super Yang-Mills.
Just the specific
super Yang-Mills theory
in four dimension.
And then we sketch group un.
OK?
Because we have D branes.
And in particular,
as we said before,
the Yang-Mills coupling
is related to the gs.
OK?
It's proportional to the gs.
And so the D3 brane give rise
to a 3 plus 1 dimensional
field theory.
In the 3 plus 1
dimensional field theory,
the Yang-Mills company
is dimensionless.
So there's no other
dimensional parameter here.
So there's only-- so there's
only numerical factor, 4 pi,
which you can work out
by explicit calculations.
So this is key, because
if there's a scale here,
then the story is more
complicated, because you
have to take alpha
goes to 0, et cetera.
OK?
So the key is that this is
a dimensionless coupling.
So they have a simple relation.
So in open string, when
you take low energy limit,
you just get a Yang-Mills
series and some finite coupling.
OK?
Which is determined by the
string coupling constant.
But in this series, there's
also closed string factor.
In a closed string
factor, again,
when you take a
low energy limit,
you get the massless modes.
You get graviton,
dilaton, et cetera.
But only massless modes.
OK?
But now, there's a
very important point.
The carpeting between the
closed and open string
are mediated through
gravitational effect.
OK?
So the coupling
between the massless--
so only massless modes are left.
So the coupling between the
massless closed and open
string, or closed
string themselves, those
interactions just-- it's
always controlled by G Newton.
This we know, because this
is a low energy limit.
Graviton, it's
controlled by G Newton.
It's gravitational by
gravitational interactions.
Another key is that g newton,
in contrast to this Yang-Mills
coupling, which
is dimensionless,
G Newton is dimensional.
And the g newton is
proportional to gs squared
alpha prime to the power of 4.
So that means, in
the low energy limit,
then the dimension
is coupling-- then
the dimensionless parameter
is g to the power, say, 8.
Because this have dimension 8.
So these is dimension--
this one goes to 0.
OK?
So that actually tells
you, in a low energy limit,
the interaction between open
and closed string will decouple.
OK?
This is our familiar fact.
That electron-- when
we talk about electron,
you don't have to
talk about gravity.
Because their energy is so
low, their gravity is so weak.
OK?
And the gravity only become
strong if their energy become
big.
OK?
It's just because of this.
In 3 plus 1, we just
GN times E squared.
But here we are in 10
dimensions, E to the power 8
doesn't matter.
So now that means, in the E
goes to 0 limit, what we find
is we find that interacting
n equals 4 super Yang-Mills
theory plus three gravitons
plus other massless modes.
But they all become free,
because the interaction
essentially switches off.
Any interaction in this
factor, they switch off.
In particular,
there's no interaction
between these two factors.
OK?
So this is what we
get on the A picture.
AUDIENCE: So the top really
is actually G Newton E8.
Times E8.
PROFESSOR: No, I'm
just saying this
is a dimensionless
combination of them.
AUDIENCE: It's the
actual coupling?
PROFESSOR: No, the actual
coupling can be 1/2.
It can be square root of these.
Controlled by the G Newton.
And the key thing, it's
controlled by G Newton.
And G Newton is a
dimensional parameter.
That's just the key.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why can't they
direct through gauge boson?
PROFESSOR: No the gauge
gauge bosons interact
with themselves.
The interaction with the
gauge boson with graviton
is gravitational.
Have to go through G Newton.
The gauge boson will
interact with themselves.
It's captured by here.
So anything involving gravity,
involve dimensional couplings,
then they will switch off
in the low energy limit.
Just like we don't have to
worry about the gravitational
interaction of an electron when
we talk about hydrogen atom.
AUDIENCE: But we know
that from [INAUDIBLE],
but how do we see
from here that--
PROFESSOR: No, no.
It's just from here.
This is just the same.
You can calculate it carefully.
You can calculate-- you can
calculate it precisely, work
out the sketching amplitude
between the photon
and the graviton, take
the low energy limit,
and you find that
sketching goes to 0.
You can do that calculation
explicitly and take the limit.
But this argument tells
you that you don't
have to do the calculation.
It will always work.
OK.
So now let's look
at Picture B, when
we take the low energy limit.
And now let's go
back to this metric.
Now let's go back
to this metric.
Actually, it's handy.
So now, let's look at picture
B, the low energy limit.
Let's look at this metric.
So this is a curved space time.
So when we take low energy
limit, we have to be careful.
Because one important
thing you always
keep in mind when you
have a curve of spacetime,
the time depends
on where you sit.
You have to always
specify a reference time.
Because time is no longer
the absolute thing.
OK?
Because at the local
time, et cetera,
you have to specify
your time frame.
OK?
And so we have to
ask what is this E?
In picture A, translate
into this picture.
In Picture A, everything
is in Minkowski spacetime.
And that E is essentially E
for the Minkowski spacetime
at the infinity in
the picture B. OK?
So in other words, the
E-- in other words--
so here, let me just say
the curve of spacetime
must be careful to
specify what energy we
are interested in, what
energy we are talking about.
OK?
So the energy depends on
now your choice of time,
or it depends on your observer.
OK?
But in order to
compare a with b,
we have to translate what is
E in A. This translated into B
is defined with respect
to the t-- this t there.
OK?
In other words, it's the
time at i equal to infinity.
OK?
So that energy scale is
defined to that specific time.
But now, when we talk
about the physics happening
in this spacetime--
for example, we're
talking about the
string theory string g
excitations of the mass
of the string, et cetera,
you have to refer to
the local proper time
at whatever place-- at
whatever place you are talking
about your physical process.
OK?
So that means-- oh, actually
today we are going to 6:30.
Yeah, right.
So suppose you are
at some location, r.
Then the local proper
time, which I will call
tau-- the local
proper time, the tau,
then it's related to the time
at infinity by this factor.
OK?
By the factor.
This-- the local observed
equals this, the tau squared.
So they're related to
this by this factor.
So now you can easily convert--
then the local proper energy
is related to the energy
we are talking about here,
by H to a power of 1/4 E. OK?
OK?
So now, it's very important,
when we take the low energy
limit, we take this E small.
But due to the gravitational
redshift effect,
this E tau does not
have to be small.
OK?
And so this is the thing
will be important here.
So when r is much,
much greater than r--
so when we are sitting
around here, then H is 1.
OK?
Then the limit E
square alpha prime
goes to 0 really just tells
you that all massive closed
string decouple.
All massive closed
OK?
In particular, though,
the interaction among
closed string themselves.
By the same argument, they
also become weaker and weaker
when you go to low energy limit.
So essentially, again,
they become free gravitons.
OK?
But now let's look at the
other regime and r around here.
OK?
So this is for that.
But now, let's consider r
smaller than R, capital R.
And then, in this regime,
we go to this AdS5 times S5.
Then H becomes R to
the power of 4, r4.
And now this statement, and
the E squared, alpha prime,
go to 0, translates.
Now you have a redshift factor.
And tau squared.
if I translate it
in tau, the local energy scale.
In particular,
now, let's remember
this r4 is given by that.
So this can be
written e tau squared
r squared 4 pi gsN goes to 0.
So now, important
thing happened.
Important thing just happened.
Then you find this alpha
prime actually canceled
with each other.
Alpha prime here and alpha prime
there, they cancel each other.
And here, there's nothing
in alpha prime left.
OK?
So when you take this limit--
when you take this limit
and it's-- then this
quantity goes to 0.
And now, E tau can
actually be anything.
As far as r sufficiently small.
OK?
So that means for any E tau,
you can even have huge energy--
local proper energy.
You can satisfy the
low energy limit
if that mode live at
r very close to 0.
Means that they live on
these throat deep enough.
So this is a very simple.
Physically, this is very simple.
Because of this
curved space effect,
because of H, this
there's a huge amount of
red shift between here
and there-- between the local
proper time here and there.
Very big energy here.
Viewed from here, can
become very, very small.
In particular, you go
deeper into this throat,
the redshift factor is bigger.
So normally, the higher the
energy, if you go deep enough,
will always appear within
the low energy limit here.
OK?
So that means, when
you sit deep enough,
that actually
anything is allowed,
including a massive stream mode.
OK?
Including massive string mode.
So now, we remember,
when r goes to 0,
essentially you get
this AdS5 times S5.
So in r equal to 0, we
just get this geometry,
which is AdS5 times S5.
So now what we find is that in
a low energy limit, in the B,
we get free gravitons
at r equal to infinity.
And then plus full string
theory AdS5 times S5.
OK?
Full string theory
AdS5 times S5.
And again, the two
factors decouple,
because when you take
the low energy limit,
then those strings in
mode have to live very far
down in the throat.
And then they have low
overlap with the graviton
and live at infinity.
OK?
And they have low overlap with
graviton and live at infinity.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I'm confused about
the way that you wrote that.
So you say three-- so
there's three gravitons that
are at infinity.
But also full string theory.
But doesn't full string
theory include gravitons?
PROFESSOR: No, no, no.
Yeah.
This is-- there's some different
graviton ideas, 5 times S5.
Full string theory
in AdS5 times S5.
Those are Minkowski
space graviton.
This is Minkowski
So this is a Minkowski
space graviton.
I think we should leave here.
The natures are very different.
OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is full string
theory only for closed strings?
PROFESSOR: Only closed string.
There's no open string
in this picture.
They're only closed strings.
OK?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No, no.
There's no artificial
separation.
That's what I just explained.
No free graviton live here.
And the string theory live
infinite down the throat.
Throat, in the low energy limit.
There are infinite--
there are essentially
as large proper distance as
you want to separate them.
Depends how low
energy you want to go.
AUDIENCE: But there is something
living at finite r, right?
There is always [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I'm just saying, when you
take the low energy limit,
then the separation
then becomes infinite.
AUDIENCE: I just don't
understand why [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No, no.
They have nothing to
do with each other.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
PROFESSOR: Geographically, one
is in this side of the galaxy.
The other is living on
the other side of galaxy.
So their wave functions have
low overlap with each other.
AUDIENCE: But with the
[INAUDIBLE] clearly something
between there.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I'm just saying when you
take the low energy limit,
then the only mode
which can survive,
other than the massless mode,
which lives around here--
just in the finite energy mode
that cannot live in this place.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Because the string
theory, or [INAUDIBLE],
flux as well?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, with the flux, yeah.
Yeah.
OK?
Then these two factors
should decouple.
So now we have derived--
see from this A equal to B,
then we take the
low energy limit.
So here, we have n equals
4 super Yang-Mills series
plus three gravitons.
And here, you have type
II B string and AdS5 times
S5 plus free graviton.
OK?
And then the free
graviton part is the same.
Then you conclude--
and they're just free.
And they interact, in
part, of both sides,
then you just equate them.
You find the input for super
Yang-Mills series with uN,
then it's equal to Type II
B strong AdS 5 times S5.
So this was a surprising
statement, saying A equal to B.
But A and B are both,
say, complicated objects.
Both are complicated objects.
But now, when we take
the low energy limit,
and then you reach
something very surprising,
because on this side,
there's no gravity.
On this side,
But this side is a
full string theory.
So now you equate
some field theory
with the full string theory.
OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So the
super Yang-Mills
is living just on the D3 brane.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Any questions
regarding this?
AUDIENCE: So for
example, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah.
But that's always valid
proper distance away.
They always valid
proper distance.
So the key is when you talk
about the general mode,
you can-- anything you talk
about is finite distance away.
If we are taking
a limit here, then
this throat is
going to infinity,
you are living infinite
down the throat.
AUDIENCE: So anything
finite is free.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
anything-- when you
talk about the finite energy,
than the story is always
complicated.
And then all this
geometry will matter.
And the thing only becomes
simple-- you really
take the E goes to 0 limit.
It's the same thing here.
Same thing, in this picture,
when we say you go to the n
equals 4 super
Yang-Mills series,
you always have to take that
limit-- E goes to 0 limit.
Then you completely
decouple the other things.
Because any tiny,
tiny non-zero E,
there's always
some gravity left.
So you really, really
have to take that energy,
go to 0 limit.
And then you rescale
the energy to be finite.
You understand what I mean?
You always have to take
that singular limit.
It's just like, when you
take the-- [INAUDIBLE]
you have to take the
infinite volume limit,
and then things become simple.
And here, it's the same thing.
Yeah.
Whenever you have
some finite energy,
there's always some
coupling between them.
Good?
So do you want to have a break?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: This is like
a physicist's guess
that, somehow, these
two must be the same.
OK?
These two must be the same.
So this is a
surprising statement.
Because on the one side,
it's a field theory.
And then on the other side,
it's a full gravity theory.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So you said that,
in principle, you
can generalize the
solution for any metric
in the full string
theory for any regime.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But in that case,
maybe you will probably not
get a geometry as same as AdS5.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's a very good question.
It turns out, indeed,
logically, you may not.
But actually, AdS 5
times S5 is a highly--
I said I will explain.
It's a very highly
symmetric space.
It turns out actually it
is exact string theory.
At least we believe it's
exact string city geometry.
And then when you include
all those corrections,
this will not change.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So with this in
mind, that means that people
don't-- they only know
this heuristically.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So there's
no actual proof
of this, besides the fact that
everyone believes it works.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It depends on what-- the label.
What do you mean--
AUDIENCE: Both.
PROFESSOR: So the
physicist, the way it works
is that 1 works, 2 works--
yeah, n equal to 1 works,
n equal to 2 works, n equal to
3 works, n equal to 4 works,
then we say it works.
And under this,
I'm way past that.
So maybe this works to n to the
10,000, something like that.
But it's not a proof.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
But it worked to
the n to the 10,000.
Something like that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Good?
So now let's talk
about this duality.
So this is normally
called AdS/CFT duality.
OK?
So to understand this
duality, let's first
understand the object
in this relation.
OK?
So let me just say a
little bit about the object
in this relation.
First, let me say a little bit
about anti-de Sitter space,
since that may not be something
you have worked before.
OK?
So one way to write the
metric is this metric.
So this is AdS5.
So this is AdS5 metric.
So you can actually
write it as AdS-- yeah,
let me just copy it down.
So you can generalize to
any number of dimensions.
You can generalize any
number of dimensions.
If we make-- if
you make this part
into a 3-dimensional
Minkowski spacetime, OK?
And then this would
be the metric of AdS--
say D plus 1 dimension.
So this is a D plus 1
dimension, Minkowski.
Than you have
another r direction.
So let we call this my-- so now
let me relabel this to be 1.
OK?
So r can be considered
as a curvature radius
of this spacetime.
So this r is a constant.
And this radius, r,
goes from 0 to infinity.
OK?
r goes to 0 from infinity.
So roughly, a
geometric picture here
is that-- so you can see
that you have half space.
OK?
You have a half space,
r from 0 to infinity.
And that each value of
r-- at each value of r,
there's a Minkowski spacetime.
There's a d dimension
Minkowski spacetime.
So if you fix r, then you just
get some d dimension Minkowski
spacetime.
And then with some pre-factor
to define the scale
of that Minkowski spacetime.
OK?
So just like this, you
have a half line-- r from 0
to infinity.
Then at each point
of this half line,
it's 48 D dimensional
Minkowski spacetime.
So that's essentially
what this does.
So the key thing is that
the Minkowski time is
what we normally called warped.
It's that the scale factor
of this Minkowski spacetime
depends on where you sit
in the radial direction.
OK?
So this r, we normally
call radial direction.
It depends on where you sit
in the radial direction.
So when your r goes to
infinity, the scale size
becomes infinite.
So this, we'd normally
call it to be the boundary.
So this we call to
be the boundary.
So r equals infinity,
we call to be
the boundary of the spacetime.
So this is similar
to, say, when we
say-- when we write-- a
Euclidean metric in this form,
when r goes to infinity, the
sphere size become infinite,
and then this is essentially
the spacetime boundary, roughly.
And so this can be
similarly understandable.
OK?
So this idea is
spacetime-- idea is
spacetime of constant
curvature-- constant negative
curvature.
OK?
In fact, this is the
most symmetric spacetime
of [INAUDIBLE]
constant curvature.
So you can easily check.
You can easily check this
satisfy the Einstein equation
with the [INAUDIBLE] constant.
So you can easily check if
you satisfied the Einstein
equation.
So now, because I'm using
this r to denote this radius,
this curvature radius.
So now I will quote my
curvature [INAUDIBLE]
always using the script now.
So also, MN now refers to
all directions in this AdS.
So you can easily check if you
satisfy this Einstein question
with some cross-module constant.
And you can just
compute the-- it's
easy to compute the
curvature of this guy.
So let me just write
down the answer.
So yeah, at first
you can-- yeah,
you can compute the
curvature of this guy.
You can just find the answer.
You find the curvature,
the rich scalar
is given by minus D
times D plus 1 R squared.
OK?
So this is a rich scalar.
This R is the same as this R.
And then similarity, you find
the cross-module constant.
Then you can find here.
It's given by minus 1/2 D
minus 1 divided by R squared.
Sorry, here it
should be minus 2.
OK?
And I said that this is the
most symmetric homogeneous
negative curvature spacetime.
So this is reflected
in that actually you
can write the Riemann
tensor-- the Riemann tensor
of this spacetime purely in
terms of this metric itself.
Without using derivative-- OK?
So this is essentially
the definition
of the most
symmetric [INAUDIBLE]
active curvature spacetime,
is that the Riemann tensor
can be written solely in
terms of metric itself.
OK?
So these are just some
facts of this space.
So often, we use a
lot of coordinates.
Sometimes it's often
convenient to use--
instead of using this r, we will
introduce another coordinate.
We introduce a z.
You go to R squared divided
by-- capital R squared
divided by small r.
Essentially, it's
just the 1 over R.
And because the capital R
goes from 0 to infinity,
then it's more z also
going from 0 to infinity.
But now, the boundary--
but now it's equal to 0
is the boundary, rather
than equal to infinity.
And then the metric
can be written
in the slightly different way
in terms of this z coordinate.
We can in this form.
OK?
You can see there is a d.
So again, here, you just
change the label r by z.
And now it's equal to
0, is the boundary.
And they're going to interior,
because one increases D.
So D equals 1 into a
different direction.
OK?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's a very good question.
I'm waiting for
some of you to ask.
So this is the physicist's
metric which we described.
Yeah, this is the
physicist's metric.
So yeah, let me just
say it this way.
So you have an infinite throat.
So going to low energy limit,
we should just go very much down
in the throat.
OK?
Because once you decouple
those decreased freedom,
then you can just
rescale your energy scale
to whatever you want.
You go to finite
energy, et cetera.
And that's why you go into AdS5.
Yeah.
Once you decouple those things,
then you are living AdS.
Then you are living
in the AdS, and then
you can talk about
the energy scale,
or any radius as you want.
It just becomes
relative to itself.
You see what I mean?
AUDIENCE: That's kind
of normalization?
PROFESSOR: No.
This is not normalization.
This is just-- normally,
when we take a low energy
limit, the reason
we take a low energy
limit is we want to decouple
those massive modes.
As once we decouple
those massive modes,
then we consider
the finite energy.
And we include
Because we consider finite
energy relative to low--
we still consider a
finite range of energy.
It's the same thing as that.
Is this clear to everybody?
This is a very important point.
Yeah.
Good.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What was the question?
PROFESSOR: The question
is that previously,
in order to decouple
those high energy
modes, when we take
a low energy limit,
we have to take r equal to 0.
And why here we worry
about r goes to infinity--
r equals infinity here?
OK?
Why are we worried
about r equals infinity.
It seems like this is going
outside our previous regime.
But the answer is that, once
we decouple those high energy
modes, then you can just
extend to whatever energy range
you want.
Because you have served
the purpose of discover--
decouple those-- yeah,
because those things already
went to infinity.
You don't have to
worry about them.
Is it clear?
Just like in the
Yang-Mills theory,
we said we take the
low energy limit.
We decouple those massive modes.
But eventually, in
the Yang-Mills theory,
we would consider very
high energy processing
in the Yang-Mills theory.
OK?
But those things we decouple
have even higher energy scale.
OK?
Good, good, good.
So we call this-- so
this is 1 and this is 2.
So in fact, actually
1 and 2, they're
not covering the full
anti-de Sitter spacetime.
So actually, they
only cover a part
of anti-de Sitter spacetime.
So they only cover, say, what
is so-called Poincare patch,
a patch of de-Sitter spacetime,
anti-de Sitter spacetime.
So now let me just mention a
little bit what is normally
called a global AdS.
OK?
So the AdS, or global
AdS-- so let me first
write down this sentence.
So 1, 2-- 1 over 2 only
covers a part of full AdS.
OK?
So the global AdS, the
so-called global AdS,
can be defined--
can be described
as a hyperboloid in
the Lorentz spacetime.
OK?
Hyperboloid in Minkowski--
d plus 2 Minkowski
spacetime of signature 2, d.
OK?
So to make this precise,
say, for example,
if you go to the
[INAUDIBLE]-- for example,
the book by Hawking and
Ellis called The Large Scale
Structure of Spacetime, the way
they define the anti-de Sitter
as follows.
So you consider d + 2 dimension
of Minkowski spacetime
with signature 2, d.
So you consider a Minkowski
spacetime like this.
OK?
So now you have d,
positive signature,
and the two negative signature.
So x starts from minus 1
index to 0, which gives you
the negative signature.
And then you have-- so this is
Minkowski spacetime of the 2,
d signature.
So now you can see that
the following hyper surface
in that spacetime.
OK?
So this is a hyperboloid
in that spacetime.
And this defines your AdS.
OK?
So this surface defines AdS.
This surface defines AdS.
So, of course, this is
a very different way
to parametrize AdS.
Then either this
metric or that metric.
And you can actually
parametrize AdS
in many, many different ways.
So now let me just
mention a few ways
to-- a few choices of different
coordinates to parametrize
this hyperboloid.
OK?
So the first is-- one is called
the Poincare coordinates.
It's this one.
So first is what we call
the Poincare coordinates.
So in this Poincare
coordinates, you introduce r.
So r there is given
by x minus 1 plus xd.
So you take the 1 over
the negative signature
and the 1 over the
positive signature.
You take x minus 1xd,
add them together.
So this is like some
kind of [INAUDIBLE].
And then you write x mu.
So there, we always
write x mu equal to tx.
OK?
So this is a three-dimensional
Minkowski coordinate.
You add x mu equal to r times
capital mu divided by r.
OK?
So in this hyperboloid,
you make this definition.
And then you restrict to the
region of r greater than 0.
Then you recover.
So 1 corresponds to r greater
than 0 part of this metric,
of this spacetime.
And you can easily
check yourself.
Just make this definition-- this
is the exercise you should do,
which I don't have
time to do here.
Just plug this in.
Plug this into that metric.
Plug this parametrization
into that metric,
and then you find
you will recover 1.
Of course, 1 is only restricted
to r equal to 0 to infinity.
So you only restrict to r
greater than 0 part of this.
And if you just introduce
this in [INAUDIBLE], of course
r can be smaller than 0.
OK?
So these are
Poincare coordinates.
So once you go to that metric,
you then go to this metric.
It's the same.
Now also let me
describe something
called the global coordinates.
So this is-- if I notice
the following structure.
So this has the form of the
difference of two squares.
So I can write-- so
let's write xi to 1
to d xi squared to
be some function,
r squared and r squared--
times r squared.
So this r have nothing
to do with that r now.
We are doing a different
set of coordinates.
I'm just using the same
notation for convenience.
So let's introduce a new
coordinate, r, which is just
the sum of all these squared.
And then I introduce--
then from this equation,
the x1 minus x0 squared
should be equal to r
squared plus 1 times r squared.
OK?
So now I can-- so
this is a circle.
So for fixed r,
For fixed r, this is a d
minus 1 dimensional sphere.
OK?
So I can introduce the d minus
1 spherical coordinates on this
and then introduce a
circular coordinate on this.
So if I do that--
so let me just call
the circular coordinate on
here tau, the polar coordinate
in the x minus y.
Polar coordinate in the x
minus 1 and the x0 plane.
So let me call this tau.
And let me call
[INAUDIBLE] coordinate
here omega d minus 1.
OK?
Then you plug this into here.
Then you find the
following metric.
So you find the
You find ds squared equal to r
squared minus 1 plus r squared
d tau squared plus the r
squared plus 1 plus r squared
plus r squared d omega
d minus 1 squared.
OK?
So remember, tau is
the polar coordinate
in this x minus 1 and x0 plane.
And the omega d minus 1 is
the polar coordinate in the x1
to xd OK?
And then you get this.
Again, it's an exercise you
should go through yourself.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I have a question.
So I'm just trying
to visualize it.
So there's these-- at least the
way it works in [INAUDIBLE].
So you have these
two sheets which
are disjoint from each other.
So how is it that this enables
us to go smoothly between them?
It seems that there's-- so maybe
I'm confused about what you
did.
PROFESSOR: What do you mean?
AUDIENCE: So we're trying to
describe this object, which
is two disjoint components.
PROFESSOR: We only
look at one component.
AUDIENCE: So what's the
point of global coordinates?
Is it just a different--
PROFESSOR: No, no, no.
No, that only covers part
of the one component.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
OK.
Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK, good.
So you look at here-- yeah.
Again, r goes from
0 to infinity.
But this r is very
different from this r now.
OK?
So in this definition,
tau is a polar coordinate.
So in this definition, tau
will go from 0 to 2 pi.
OK?
But once you write it in this
form, nothing depends on tau.
So you can extend tau
to any range you want.
So once we write
this form, we take
tau goes to minus
infinity to plus infinity.
So this is [INAUDIBLE],
rather than from 0 to 2 pi,
we take tau from minus
infinity to plus infinity.
So sometimes, this is
also called extended AdS.
Sometimes people don't
just bother to do that.
You just extend
it automatically.
OK?
So strictly speaking, this,
as a definition of AdS,
only corresponding to the
part of tau from 0 to 2 pi.
OK?
And when you extend
tau from minus infinity
to plus infinity, you actually
have an infinite copy of this.
OK.
So now, with one more thing,
we can-- so this coordinate
is nice.
Now it covers everything.
Covers everything, but even
actually a little bit more.
Because now you extend
the tau to minus infinity.
We can visualize
this metrically.
It might be better by
doing the following.
Allow the transformation.
So now let's take--
yeah, before I do
that, let me say a
few words about-- let
me just do this first.
Let's take tau again.
Take r equal to tangent rho.
Rho is some other coordinate.
And r from 0 to infinity.
Then rho would be from
0 to 2 pi, pi over 2.
OK?
0 to pi over 2.
And you park this into
here with a little bit
tiny-- so after two seconds,
you find the following metric.
OK?
So this is easy to see.
Because 1 plus
[INAUDIBLE] rho squared
is just 1 over cosine
squared, et cetera.
So the reason this
metric is nice,
because other than
this conformal factor,
this thing we can
easily rationalize.
So this is just a cylinder.
Let me draw it here.
So this is a cylinder.
OK?
So this direction
can be considered--
the radial direction
is the rho direction.
And this direction
is the tau direction.
And this direction is
the omega d minus 1,
or the polar
coordinate direction.
I'm only drawing one of them.
OK?
So essentially, this I have
a structure of a cylinder.
And at the center here,
I have rho equal to 0.
And here, I have rho
equal to pi over 2.
OK?
Took rho from 0 to pi over 2.
And when you go to pi over 2,
its quotient factor goes to 0.
So the overall scale blows up.
But here is your boundary.
So pi over 2-- yeah, so
pi over 2 is the boundary.
OK?
Is this clear?
So pi over 2 is the boundary.
Now the boundary map.
So the boundary of the
cylinder-- so the boundary now
is sitting at rho
equal to pi over 2,
has the topology of
r times s d minus 1.
OK?
So the boundary itself,
it's-- so the boundary itself,
it's a cylinder.
The whole space is
a solid cylinder.
It's a field cylinder.
OK?
But the scale factor blows up
when you approach the boundary,
because of this prefactor.
And the r is the time
and the sd minus 1
is the-- now, to visualize
this space a little bit better,
let's look at the cross section.
So imagine you put a
plane in this space.
OK?
So now let me call this circular
direction, it's called theta.
And then now let's
consider the cross section
across this solid cylinder.
So then we just have a plane.
OK?
A plane.
I should not have-- let's
consider this cross section.
OK?
In the center of this cylinder.
Cut half.
Cylinder cut in half.
So for example,
in this notation,
so this will be rho equal to 0.
So here is rho
equal to pi over 2.
And I introduced this
angular coordinate.
So that equals 1 into
theta equal to 0.
And here will be, again, rho
equal to pi over 2 of theta
equal to pi.
OK?
And again, this is
the tau direction.
Is it clear what I'm doing?
I cut the cylinder in half,
and that's that cross section.
So now, because of
the structure of this
times a conformal factor
overall, a scale factor.
So the propagation
of a light ray
does not depend on
this overall factor.
The propagation of that
ray can be seen from here.
OK?
So now, let's consider
radial light ray,
which only goes into
the rho direction.
There's no in this
angular direction.
Let's consider radial light ray.
Then from that picture,
it's very clear--
let's say this is
tau equal to 0.
Then it actually
takes only pi over 2
for light ray to
reach the boundary.
OK?
Because rho only
goes from pi over 2,
and light ray always
travel in 45 degrees.
So this is just like-- if
you look at the [INAUDIBLE]
plus the rho squared,
this is Minkowski.
And so light ray
travel 45 degree.
And then you reach the boundary.
And then take log of pi over 2.
Yeah, so this is pi over 2.
So this is tau equal to 0.
And then this would be
tau equal to pi over 2.
Then suppose that you put
some reflecting wall here.
And by the time tau equal
to pi, it has bounced back.
OK?
And now, if you go
another round, then
at tau equal to 2
pi, then precisely
go back to the origin.
Then go through a period.
OK?
And that actually
precisely is tau
equal to 2 pi, which would
define the angular coordinates.
If you follow that,
then that equals 1
into precisely one period
of the light ray traveling.
OK?
But the key thing is that the
light ray will travel pi over 2
to the boundary.
And now you can check.
If you look at--
not the light ray.
So light ray travels along
the light magnitude axis.
But if you look at the
time magnitude axis,
which is travelled
by massive particle,
then you can show that the
massive particle never reach
the boundary.
We'll go into a
motion like this.
OK?
So this is a massive particle.
So the massive particle will
never reach the boundary.
It will always be
reflected back intuitively,
from the gravity potential.
OK?
So you will show
this fact yourself.
And your P-set show that
actually the massive particle
will never reach the boundary.
So in a sense, so if you
look at this metric, at rho
equal to 0, at rho equal
to 0, this is essentially
like a flat metric.
Because at rho equal to
0, this is just a sphere.
So this becomes 1.
This is a sphere.
Yeah.
Rho equal to 0, this is
just like Euclidian space.
Because the sine of rho
squared become rho squared.
OK?
So this just becomes
like a Euclidian space
in polar coordinates.
And then you have a time.
And then this scale
factor becomes 1.
So at rho equal to 0, just like
you have ordinary Minkowski
spacetime.
And then the curvature comes
in when you go to finite rho,
and then those factors
become important.
And then you can show--
yeah, just because of that,
you can show that the massive
particle will never actually
travel to the boundary.
OK?
Always reflected back.
In some sense, you can think
that the massive particle
is always pulled back by
the gravitational potential.
OK?
Pulled by gravitational
potential.
So from a different
point of view,
it's that another way to say it
is a familiar statement, which
people often make and often
can give you great intuition,
physical intuition in
many physical problems,
is that AdS is like
a confining box.
Just like a box.
So things cannot escape from it.
OK?
And in particular, the
typical curvature radius is r.
So you can roughly imagine
this-- because in the center,
it's like a flat space.
So it's more like
a box of size r.
OK?
You can heuristically think
of it as a box of size r.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Does it have finite
or infinite volume?
PROFESSOR: Hm?
AUDIENCE: Does it have
finite or infinite volume?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it
has infinite volume.
AUDIENCE: It's infinite volume.
OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
But because it's confining,
most of the particles
will only see the sides r.
AUDIENCE: So one other question.
So is it correct to say that
it's like an antiharmonic trap?
So if I'm in the space,
and I throw a ball
that it's going to come
and hit me back in the head
or something like that?
It seems like--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Right, right.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It'll bounce back?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah, actually, our own friend,
Frank Wilczek, in the '80s,
have tried to use these
ideas, this feature, to say,
maybe this actually
describes confinement.
Because if you put [INAUDIBLE]
there, they're confined.
Anyway.
Yeah, but keep this
heuristic picture in mind.
Because many physical
problems actually,
if you think in terms of this
picture, become very intuitive.
OK?
OK.
And often-- so you say this is
an exception for the light ray.
But often, we impose
the reflecting boundary
coming on the light ray.
And from the light ray,
this is also like a box.
And you go to the boundary,
and you bounce back, et cetera.
OK?
So now let me again just say it.
But you should go back
to check yourself.
Now, by looking at the
relation between here--
so here is a specific
relation between r and x.
And here is a specific
relation between this
x and this tau and this r.
You can find the relation
between this Poincare
coordinate and this
global coordinate.
OK?
Use a little bit effort.
And then you can show yourself--
let me just draw the picture.
Again, using the same picture.
You can show that the Poincare
patch cover a wedge-- say
in this cross section.
The Poincare patch cover a cross
section of this global AdS.
OK?
So here is tau
equal to minus pi.
And here is tau
equal to plus pi.
And here, say tau equal to 0.
And in this Poincare patch-- and
then this 9 become r equal to 0
and t equal to minus infinity.
And this line become r equal
to 0 and t plus infinity.
OK?
Plus infinity.
So the time essentially
goes around like this.
Time goes around like this.
And this line
equals t equal to 0.
OK?
So t equal to 0
and tau equal to 0
coincides, and then goes
to minus infinity rotating
into that.
And the constant r
surface-- so this
is a constant r surface in
the Poincare coordaintes--
goes like this.
So the time goes up.
OK?
And you can check yourself
just by working out
the relation between those
coordinates through the x.
AUDIENCE: You mean this is
wrapped on the cylinder?
PROFESSOR: No, no, no.
No, I'm just saying--
AUDIENCE: This picture?
PROFESSOR: Just within
this cross section,
I can look at this
cross section,
I see how this translates
into Poincare coordinates.
And that's what's happening.
A Poincare coordinate
covers this part.
OK?
It cover this part.
I can also draw a more
fancy picture here.
Then roughly, what
you can show is
that in this general
picture, the Poincare patch
covers something like this.
OK?
And the region between
these two lines.
So this is a spacial infinity
of the-- in this Poincare patch,
the boundary is
Minkowski spacetime.
So you see-- so the Poincare
patch cover like that.
And then this is
a spatial infinity
over the Minkowski spacetime.
This is times infinity and
times a path in the Minkowski
spacetime.
OK?
So I urge use to do it yourself.
Because this kind
of thing, you really
have to work through yourself to
have intuitive feeling for it.
But this the picture.
Once you work hard yourself,
you compare with my picture,
and then you will understand.
OK?
So I will stop here today.
So in some sense-- yeah, let
me just say one more sentence.
This extended ideas
contain infinite copies
of this Poincare patch.
OK?